all right good morning welcome to
jailcar it is nine o'clock and we're
starting our regular meeting
uh I recommend we see representative
groda for representative hatch and
representative pack and Phillips for
Senator Whitley
and we have a quorum so
the minutes of the previous meeting
okay
moved by representative Schmidt second
by Senator Lang are there any additions
or corrections to the minute
all right seeing none those in favor
aye aye opposed
all right the consent agenda
uh I'd like to remove the second item
the board of acupuncture licensing which
was placed on consent and error
um sorry yes representative land um
thank you I would actually like to
remove h i
um
rsnt please
numbers up sorry the
fp2022-240 the reimbursement for mileage
um the
fp2023-2 dental services
and then the ones about the license or
surveys there's one question removed
from all of them
um that I have a question on
so those are exrf 2023 one two and four
all right any other removals from
consent
all right about
those in favor of uh proving the rest of
the consent agenda say I I opposed
all right
director tomorrow should we deal with
the off consent first or do you think
the uh
whatever you prefer
regular calendar first then because I
think it's a
should be more straightforward
Uptown Health officers
I believe the town Health officers was
on the consent agenda I don't was that
removed oh
uh the calendar I just got is okay oh
forgive me
the immunization registry rules yes
that's a little different sorry excuse
me that's fine I just want to make sure
I didn't miss that one being removed
um so with regards to the immunization
rules
that has not changed from the interim
rule that was filed last year as 2022 5.
the only reason it's on the regular
agenda is because there was a number of
comments on it when it was an interim
rule so we wanted to keep it on the
regular agenda and additionally there
were two notes to jail car on pages two
and three of the rules
regarding those forms that are mentioned
those forms are not being updated in
this particular rule but the department
has stated that they're in the rule
making process
to update those along with other rules
in order to implement HB 1606 which I
believe becomes effective this summer
okay
good morning Allison radmay
administrator of the administrative
rules unit for the Department of Health
and Human Services
um just as attorney Reichert had said
um we are moving forward with revisions
to
Hep 307
307 and 301.
um to incorporate HB 1606 that does
become effective this summer we are
still in the heavy drafting stages
within the department but we do expect
to start rulemaking on that within the
next few weeks
uh so that I hope the intent is that
those forms are the updated forms are
available before the start of school
okay any other questions or comments
representative Leon
um thank you madam chair I have a
question about some of the wording on
the Forum I know it was approved
previously but it says that it's at a
request for a religious exemption
however in our statutes it's not a
request it's a it's a right
um and I'm concerned that stating it as
a request would lead to some some
facilities not accepting this religious
exemption that is under the please
specify the vaccines for which this
exemption applies on the New Hampshire
child care school immunization form or
the religious exemption form
foreign
not sure that I
good morning my name is Ian Marie
McCurry I'm the immunization section
chief for the Department I'm happy to
answer any questions I'm sorry
representative Leon I'm not sure exactly
where you're specifying would you please
clarify
um thank you if you have the school
immunization form in front of you when
you look just above the check boxes for
the various vaccines it says on that
line your request for a religious
exemption a request implies that it can
be rejected
but the law says that if you have a
religious exemption
a child shall be exempt from
immunization if the parent signs this
form
we're okay with removing that if okay
may I ask is there a specific term that
you would rather have in place
um I would just strike the words request
for religious exemption so it says it
will not impact your religious exemption
because I appreciate those clarifying
words because they're a big concern
about those check boxes
thank you
any other questions or comments
Senator move to approve as edited okay
further discussion
discussion to approve as edited
all in favor
aye opposed
okay thank you very much thank you
um
different ones
all right uh Board of Medicine
okay so um
2022-191 is on Severance of connection
and changes of address
you'll see in front of you is a one-page
proposal it's pretty short the only
reason why it's not on consent is
because one of these rules has been
expired since May of last year and
that's on the section regarding changes
of address which
um you know requires that applicants or
licensees report changes of address
within 30 days time and that if mail is
returned back to the board for a wrong
address the the board will issue a
letter of concern like I said that's the
only issue is that the rules have been
expired since last May
thank you
good morning Tina Kelly
um office of professional licensure and
certification what the board did for
that section was relied on RSA 329 colon
16--f Roman numeral one which states
exactly the same thing
okay so what were any uh
doctors discipline for for not reporting
a change of address
not that I'm aware of
all right Senator move to a proof
I mean discussion
all right those in favor
opposed
all right we have that one
team and
oh yes licensure regulated professions
so for this particular item 2022
9 the agency did file a conditional
approval which did address the majority
of the comments however there were still
some that remained and additionally some
new comments that were made because the
conditional approval included a
universal
initial licensure form a universal
temporary license form Universal renewal
form and
form for the temporary active military
license applications which could
potentially conflict with boards that
already have forms for these particular
license
so there was a note to jailcar on page
one about that
um
one of the remaining comments from the
FP is on page one it's an unclear note
to gel car comment as there seemed to be
some overlap between the language in
this in the particular section cited and
PLC 213 which is disciplinary
proceedings and license conditions
in the opleas summary of comments it is
represented that there is little overlap
between the two and that the oplc will
review what is currently in PLC 213 to
see if anything should be moved to the
300s
the next comment
um
is a unclear legislative intent common
on page two of the conditional approval
text
they have at the very end of the
requirements essentially an
all-encompassing requirement that if
is not listed it will apply or need to
be submitted if it's not listed in what
is already in the text
they that may cause some issues because
they may be incorporating information
from third parties which would need a
corporation by reference form
or they may require information that
cannot be incorporated by reference on
the form but actually has to be stated
in the rule text this comment is also
made for
um later in that section B8 and
additionally
um on page 25.
on page three of the final proposal and
on page one of the conditional approval
text there's another
no-till GL car that the changed language
includes disclosure or personal
information for individuals and the
email address for legal entities
um
essentially what the agency is saying is
that the person or the entity if they do
not wish to disclose that information to
the public can indicate that on the form
however this may conflict with our say
91a
should it go to a court the court would
Implement a balancing test on the
individual or the entity's right to
privacy over the public interest and at
this time it's staff's opinion that it
may be too encompassing or too much of
an overreach to deny the public that
information
on page three of the conditional
approval text there is also
an unclear comment as there's a request
on the in the text for the verification
of licensures but it's not seen on the
form that was submitted to OLS
and finally on page nine of the final
proposal text the form requires that the
applicant
um
excuse me the form that was submitted to
OLS says that the requirement that is
being asked for is for applicants of
repress a property only but it's not
clear in the rule text that that is the
case the rule text just says that that
information should be provided so there
is some discrepancy between the form and
the role text
good morning Madam chair members of the
committee for the record Lindsey
Courtney I'm the executive director of
oplc
um just briefly I think uh kind of a
broad overview of what we're trying to
do here would address some of the
staff's comments
oplc has now has statutory authority
over licensing procedures and the boards
have statutory authority over licensing
criteria all of the boards previously
had statutory authority over procedures
and so they all had different forms
which has led to issues with respect to
data and how we're managing our system
so what we are trying to do is come up
with what we call a universal
application with respect to procedures
or basically everything that the boards
have on on their own applications in
different formats so I call that page
one and then page two will be whatever
the specific criteria is that relates to
that profession in order to make this
happen we need to have page one in place
first and then we need to go back and
modify page two to make sure that the
board forms are limited to criteria so
certainly there will be a conflict as
this committee has seen as oplc has
obtained additional legislative
Authority
um
it's the only way that we think we can
actually manage it so that's with
respect to the first comment with
respect to the second comment in plc2
uh 213. the 200s deal with disciplinary
proceedings which are very different
from adjudicating licensing applications
we don't view it as a conflict
um the reason why this is important is
because in a licensing proceeding where
somebody does not have a license the
burden is on the applicant to
demonstrate why they qualify for
licensure in a disciplinary proceeding
the burden is on the prosecutor to show
why the license should be there should
be conditions on the license so there's
two separate proceedings and they don't
view that as a conflict
with respect to
um I think it was page 25 it's also on
page one with respect to disclosure of
personal information the Department of
Justice has taken the position and has
advised all agencies including ours that
email addresses are confidential and so
therefore
we do not as a matter of course disclose
email addresses however it has been a
long-standing practice for many of our
boards to give out email addresses to
associations what we are trying to do is
allow individuals to consent and it we
believe that it's their right to consent
to disclosure of their private
information and if they choose to
consent to disclosure we would release
that information if they choose not to
disc consent a disclosure we would not
release that information
yes this is relevant to email addresses
only and not mail addresses
um they could consent under the proposed
rules to mail addresses as well
isn't that Public public information is
there we've been advised that
um from our perspective doj has advised
us that personal mailing addresses are
confidential business mailing addresses
are not so we do give out business uh
mailing addresses but the problem is
going back to page one the boards have
collected this information in different
ways so we can't do a data export to
really provide that information in a
user accessible format so we'd like to
create a a scenario where we are
capturing both personal and business and
if individuals want to consent to
disclosure personal information for
whatever reason they can do that
specific question so please continue
okay
um so uh regarding the comment
regarding the comment that
um oplc is requesting that individuals
submit basically any other documentation
that is otherwise required that goes
back to the page one versus page two we
cannot reasonably be expected to list
everything that any licensed
professional would ever be required to
submit
according to the board rules on this
page one application so what we're
saying is that you have to follow page
one and then you have to follow page two
whatever that may be
um and and unfortunately because we have
so many license types we can't list all
of those page twos and then finally with
respect to reciprocity only I would
agree with that comment that we can
certainly make that change
that the requirement to submit a
verification of licensure in another
state clearly only applies to those
seeking licensure by endorsement or
reciprocity
granting a license by reciprocity you
you confirmed that the requirements from
that other state are substantially
similar
uh it depends on the statutory mechanism
under which uh the license is granted so
there are many different reciprocity
applications that we have for those and
I just did whip this with funeral the
other day uh for those who are seeking
licensure under 332gs analysis that
require substantial equivalency we do
require that the board make a
determination that the requirements are
substantially equivalent before we issue
the license
um some boards already have in rules a
reciprocity based uh
mechanism for obtaining a license in the
statutory Authority for that is not 332g
and so therefore we follow that process
in those rules
okay but in general you do verify that
they meet the minimum requirements oh
absolutely absolutely thank you I had
some some questions from people as to
whether that was the case so I wanted to
confirm it yes
yes representative
so along with the information that we're
that is collected on those people the
individuals licenses other social
security numbers I would think correct
yes it's a requirement of state law
which is incorporated uh incorporating
federal law which dates back to child
support obligations that we are required
to collect Social Security numbers on
all licensing applications
so how does one protect that information
when when people say you can do you can
just you know just you can distribute my
information
how is it that just that that process is
selected and Social Security numbers
aren't sent flying around oh yes no
that's that's a very good question so um
if we're doing a data export we would
export
um particular data fields that obviously
would not include Social Security
numbers and there's
um we always have two people check the
data fields to make sure that they are
accurate data fields
and you do have the uh
uh the option of individuals not
contending to share their data
we have the option of individuals not
consenting or yes if individuals don't
consent to disclosure of confidential
information we don't disclose that and
right now we don't have a mechanism for
people to consent so we aren't
disclosing anything which is actually
cause problems with some of our friends
and stakeholders
um because they have always received
this data uh in the past so we'd like to
provide that opportunity for people to
consent but right now we're not we're
not disclosing anything now if it's
public information under 91a obviously
we we certainly do disclose that
information but that's typically name
and license number
thank you madam chair so in the past
some of the county Registries I think
all of them as a matter of fact
included Social Security numbers uh on
in their records and then a number of
them have gone online and that is there
and that stuff became searchable and it
became a problem because the social
security numbers are right out there in
the open I think most of them have taken
steps to uh to try to
stop that and I'm wondering whether your
files any of them are searchable online
and thus you would have a similar
problem with them if you're requiring
the social security numbers
uh we do have an online system and duat
has fully vetted it um it's been online
for years you can search for individuals
licenses but Social Security is not the
data that's that's published
okay okay thank you good to know other
questions
right please continue
those are all my um comments in response
to staff comments
okay
yes absolutely you're on the board
oh
so I'm Sally fellows state
representative for Grafton 8.
um my first question has to do with the
use of the portal
to file an application it seems to be
the only option that's available
so my concern is that
um
there are a lot of people that might be
applying for a license that only have a
cell phone to use they don't have a
computer
some of the applications require that
they write a narrative about their
experience and to try to do that on a
cell phone would be
really difficult plus I assume that you
want them to upload transcripts
things like that and then they would
need a printer with a scanner
so it appears to me from me from what I
saw in the proposed rules that you've
eliminated the paper option can you
address that
yes
um we presently only conduct renewals
online so for the large majority of our
200 and something thousand licensees
they're only renewing their license
online through the portal we have a
kiosk
um and and people readily they typically
will make appointments with their staff
and we'll walk them through it as this
committee is aware we are currently
upgrading our system we'll be mobile
friendly so those individuals who have
cell phones will be able to apply online
through an app
um you know to take pictures of their
documentation and upload it's what
people who are entering their Workforce
and applying for new licenses now are
essentially demanding because that's how
they're conducting all of their
businesses additionally we have found
that that is the way to for us to be
most efficient I recognize that for all
all people it's not going to be one size
fits all which is why we have the kiosk
option but in terms of manual data entry
that requires a significant amount of
time of Staff time that
that the licensing portal will eliminate
by receiving applications electronically
it'll also eliminate the opportunity for
errors
so in the rollout of the renewal process
we haven't observed any significant
issues with that obviously some people
are not fans but but for the most part
it's gone off without a hitch and it's
been using a portal that is ancient so I
suspect with a new portal it'll be even
be better
follow up
so the current rules do say that there
can be a paper application so you know
have not been making that available we
have paper applications in the office if
for whatever reason somebody Demands a
paper application but our experience has
been that when we walk people through
the process and educate them that they
much prefer the electronic process
okay
so I I think it's it is important to
maintain a paper option at least till
you get your app up and running because
there are some old fogies out there who
don't who prefer not to do it on cell
phones and I believe there are also some
boards that require substantial amounts
of paper
in addition to the The Forum so for
those boards in particular we would want
to have a uh an option yeah so we we
have to maintain our paper documentation
if for nothing else other than
continuity of operations you know for
system kind of we're shutting order shut
down we need our documentation
um I would say that
um I mean we're happy to continue to
offer that as a customer service option
that said
um
it does come at an increased cost in
terms of additional staff support so
that's something that I think um you
know the commit the committee should be
aware you know Vermont has a similar
process and they are able to issue
licenses in 24 hours and so from a
Workforce standpoint when when people
are submitting things to be a snail mail
we are not able to do that and
um if we want to be competitive uh with
our neighboring states in terms of how
quickly we turn around licenses
licensing applications I think that the
electronic application is the way to go
Senator Lang so I just want to be clear
and summarize all that conversation so
in short people can file online if they
wanted yes they can come into your
office and you have staff to help them
if they want to file online using a
kiosk that's available to them in your
office correct and the third part you
also have paper available if someone
comes in your office and wants to apply
by paper correct thank you okay
and I
do hope that as we're streamlining the
boards that we simplify the amount of
specific paper that needs to be handled
when I'm doing this correctly so are are
you going will the rules be amended to
identify the fact that a paper option is
still available because right now that's
a there's a cross out line through that
um what I would suggest if if that is
the committee's desire
um I would suggest language to the
effect of
a paper application shall be made
available when an electronic version is
not practicable and the reason why I'd
like that language is because when we
started rolling out the renewals for
cosmetology cosmetologists have have
always done everything via paper uh they
they were not happy about having to move
to the electronic format we
um but once we got him there it it's
working and it's now we're seeing
greater compliance with licensure
renewal cosmetologists had a history and
a pension of just letting their licenses
lapse and then coming back two years
later and paying the extra five dollars
and get so
um we want we want people to try it and
that's why I would ask for that language
when you give them the option I think
what we'll see is that maybe 20 30
percent will choose paper and from a
staff Staffing it perspective that's not
something that we it can easily be
managed
okay thank you other questions or
comments
represent fellows so
um thank you and I I hope that you'll
you'll want to be a customer friendly
agency and make that known on the
website that they do have that option if
it the portal doesn't work if they don't
think they can use the portal but it's
obvious to them so I had a question
about the conversation that we just had
about the addresses and I'm wondering if
I wanted to look up somebody's license
and they had a fairly common name
wouldn't I need to see their address or
a part of the town to know if that's or
at least the town to know if that's the
person I'm thinking about you know Mary
Smith you know is she licensed
yeah I mean I potentially I think
um
you know we take protecting people's
private information very seriously
um and so we could certainly have the
conversation about whether providing the
town is sufficiently de-aggregated
um
but
um but that has not been an issue that
has been raised to us in the past so
um
we have not made it a practice of
publicizing people's
portions of people's addresses
typically people rely on a license
number you know they when they go to
visit a licensed professional
um almost all boards require that a
license be displayed and there's a
number associated with that which is a
public identifier
so I'm just thinking of a perspective
from the person who wants to know does
so and so have a license for this that I
thought that your portal well whatever I
know I can go to the website and I can
look up somebody's name under a specific
certification
and I'm just isn't that part of your job
to so people will know if somebody's
licensed or not
yeah they want to find that out so how
how do they know that they don't have
some kind of address again I think most
people if you go to for example a salon
they are required mandated to not what
I'm asking I'm asking if I want to know
ahead of time is so and so licensed as
whatever
yeah we provide that information online
the town we do not provide the town
because again doj the Attorney General's
office has advised us that releasing
um addresses personal addresses and
again we don't have a mechanism right
now to differentiate between business or
personal addresses
um that releasing that information is
considered confidential and not subject
to 91a
now I would agree with you that perhaps
releasing just the town may not be
subjects may not may be sufficiently
de-aggregated
practically I don't know whether DUI T
and again it's not an oplc system it's
an Enterprise solution that is extremely
agent could do a data extract that's
limited just to the county maybe we
could we've never had this issue raised
because typically people have the
license number and they're able to
verify that information through that
specific identifier but if there were a
case where you wanted to verify before
you got into business with this person
could you say well is Bob Williams of uh
Lebanon a licensed electrician yes
credits you would be we would be able to
call up the office assuming there's 17
Bob Williams in the state and say is
this person a licensed electrician yes
you can even request a letter of
verification if you want it okay thank
you does that help yes okay any
representative Lynn yeah so I just want
to make sure that I'm understanding I
thought you had said earlier that the
the place of business of the licensee is
public
it is considered public information it's
not something that we publicized because
from a technological standpoint
um the boards have not always
consistently captured that and so
um that's what page one is trying to
address to make sure that we are
capturing the same data set for
everybody so that we can make
agency-wide decisions as to what can be
posted and what can't be posted when the
portal was established all of the boards
were operating on their own and so they
came up with their own demographics and
they came up with their own address
requirements and they came up with you
know do you capitalize do you not
capitalize and by virtue of that there's
no way for us to consistently
distinguish between business and
personal in the portal and that's why we
just don't extract any of that
information because we can't confirm
that it is business versus personal but
but couldn't you say on the couldn't you
say on page one of the portal
list your business address and why what
would be the problem with that list your
business address and then they list
their business address well that's what
this is exactly intended to allow us to
do we need that application first to
capture that information and then we
fully anticipate being able to release
the business address but we don't have
that capacity rate right okay I should
say but you're but that but you're
planning to do that yes yes
but Senator line move to conditionally
approved with staff edits and comments
made today
is there a second
Ed by representative Ms oh senator in
his excuse me
uh those in favor
aye opposed
all right thank you very much and while
we're uh into licensed professions why
don't we take up uh
the acupuncture licensing and fees that
came out off consent if that's uh
yeah that's uh
final proposal 2020 to 170 ACP 300.
so
um
this is a little confusing we had some
some mistakes
um with this one
um it is on acupuncture licensing and I
think I understood from the executive
director this would be page two okay
um
so there actually is just one very minor
editorial comment on the form what
happened with this is
the staff at the agency filed
um the final proposal appropriately
and then we had some issues with gel car
staff
um
there was a typo in our database
um and because that can happen the
database is old and and quite difficult
to use some time we have kind of a
second layer and so the
staff puts in
the numbers so that we can pull like
reports and stuff and then they email
they forward the attorneys the
information and
there was a typo and so the second layer
is the emails and
um
I believe that I accidentally deleted
the email
and so we didn't get the timing
correctly so technically
this has already been
approved like a you know like a pocket
approval
um because we missed the deadline but I
think you you did get a waiver right we
we had a waiver on Monday which
according to the um
the director was approved prior to the
time the rule would go into effect
without jail car meeting on it okay
but so that that's the weird thing
happening with this but
um other than that there's there's
nothing wrong with the rule so
so nice to hear also questions or
comments I have implemented um a new
system for my email so that I don't
don't do that again
move to approve
any discussion
seeing none those in favor
aye opposed
all right thank you very much thank you
all right Pam coming back with regular
calendar back to uh the EMS
and then those things that came off
consent
okay so
2023-11 on EMS letters of concern and
denial this proposal makes changes to
the rules on Emergency Medical Services
and it inserts a definition and criteria
for when the commissioner will issue
letters of concern for when an EMS
worker has committed an act or offense
in violation of the statute and there
are three main issues to discuss and
I'll take each one in turn
the first one is on page five of the
linked PDF which is page one of the rule
proposal
and you'll see that comment on the upper
left hand corner
so the department was previously in
regular rule making with this rule set
and missed the final proposal deadline
they did enter into interim rule making
which was approved and adopted but those
rules have expired as of November so
what you're seeing is on that first
section there that applies to the letter
of concern definition that that has been
expired since November so that's the
first issue to bring to your attention
um the second one is on the same page
you'll see a comment in the middle of
the page that says public interest
potentially inadequate fist
so here um the agency has inserted a new
section a new Amendment if you will
um so
5908.01 was not included in the notice
and it was not included you know in the
initial proposal so which means that um
it wasn't submitted over to the LBA and
like I said it wasn't included in the
notice the changes here are highlighted
so you'll see what changes they made to
that section
the changes are are minor and they are
in line with the rest of what they're
doing in this proposal there may not be
a cost I I don't know but you may be
concerned about any Associated cost and
you might be concerned about the lack of
notice to the public for changes made to
this particular section
I can go on to the next one but if you
want me to stop there and we can do that
why don't we hear
from the agency on this one
hi Aaron Johnson uh rules coordinator on
behalf of safety so with that we
actually did reference the notice
um we pointed out in the first line of
the notice that
rsa153 a131
basically talks about letters of concern
and the rulemaking authority that we
have over them
um and pretty much what happens here is
in the process between the initial
proposal and the final proposal we
realized that there was a little bit of
ambiguity where there could have been a
potential cost that wasn't calculated
um when in fact that was never safety's
intent
um to where
in 5908.01 if if we look through it it's
basically saying the commissioner shall
not impose both a fine and any of the
other things originally it was just a
revoc a revocation or a suspension that
was also supposed to include a um a
letter of concern
foreign
I'm afraid that doesn't quite make sense
so the statute as I recall when we
passed it had a added a letter of
concern as among the options available
for discipline exactly that's
is that correct correct okay so that
your
this rulemaking is amending your rules
to allow a letter of concern in addition
to the fine and so and license denial
and so forth that was already in statute
and rules is that correct it's not
at well it's adding an option to be a
letter of concern but it's not imposing
both an option or a a fine animal right
they're just adding among the uh
discipline options the letter of concern
as well as the fine and the licensed in
oil that was already in statute and
rules correct
thank you that makes a little more sense
anyone else have a question
all right thank you
okay so the um last comment and it's um
they're related so I'll take them
together you'll see on pages eight and
nine at the bottom of page eight
um and that is going to be
that's page eight on the linked PDF at
page four the rule down at the bottom of
the of page eight and then at the top of
page nine I'll take these together
because they're kind of similar
um so this section of the rule is
talking about suspensions of licenses
and
um and the reason why we have a comment
here is because basically the rule lacks
criteria to describe for when a
deferment of a suspension
or when a rescission of that suspension
will be granted or not so basically the
rule says that a suspension may be
deferred for up to one year conditioned
upon good behavior and completion of any
requirements that need to be met but it
doesn't describe how the agency will
decide to do that how what criteria is
going to weigh in order to to defer that
suspension or not and that's basically
the same issue on the next page
regarding when the agency will rescind
that suspension the rule says that the
suspension may be rescinded upon the
licensees correction of the violation
but it doesn't say that it definitely
shall be and it doesn't give us any
criteria to to know or for the public to
know how that decision is going to be
made if they correct the violation
so the criteria is actually listed in
5922.11 and that's going to be on page
six of the final proposal
okay here it talks about suspension
um and it lists all the the various
reasons for the suspension but like I
said it's not
you know giving us um when you know if
if I as a licensee you know correct my
violation the rule doesn't say that that
um that suspension will definitely be
rescinded or deferred
uh good morning my name is Jeffrey
Phillips I'm the system director at the
fire academy in EMS
um the the I guess the operational tact
that we've always done is 59 22 11 which
outlines the criteria outlines the
criteria for the actual sanction and
also the level of disciplinary action
um so we typically will uh if we issue a
suspension uh depending on the severity
outlined in 59 22 11 will determine
whether the suspension can be deferred
whether it goes into place
um
at this time there's been no suspensions
that I'm aware of or replications have
been aware of that have been rescinded
um but essentially the criteria that's
outlined um and 5922 is utilized for
both the the level of sanction
um and also the
um
level of discipline
assessed
senator
so as I look at uh 2211 there I'm
assuming that the things in here you
have that mitigate and extenuating
circumstances so things that are
presented the cooperation of the
individual or agency being suspended
these are the kind of things that way
that will alter possibly the remove the
concerns and above about the criteria
right you'll use those considerations to
say all right you've resolved all the
issues you cooperated with our you took
responsibility so therefore we're going
to lift your suspension
uh correct and it also depends on what
the infraction is um you know I mean
because I'm in the world of EMS no two
calls are the same
um so it really uh whatever the
mitigating factors of the specific
incident if it's a protocol violation
really depends on the severity of the
pro of a protocol violation so really
the in the totality of the investigation
of the cooperation of this the service
or the unit or the provider in regards
to the individual instances of the
specifics of the actual caller instance
are all taken into consideration in
regards to that specific
thank you
director
um I understand that the intent of 59 22
11 is to apply to rescinding
um
the action too but it says in imposing
any sanctions under this part so it it's
only talking about imposing sanctions
it's not about rescinding a sanction
and it um
doesn't specifically address when it
will be suspended although you know
clearly you can look at that and say
well this one is likely to be suspended
but
um
it doesn't
doesn't seem to address the that that
issue either correct even though the
criteria are there in 59 22 11 the other
Rule still says May so regardless of the
criteria uh the Department's leaving
itself the option to do it or not
yeah I guess I'm I I I agree with the
with the way you read it but I'm not
what's the problem with that I mean is
the is the idea that the department
shouldn't have any discretion uh
no they absolutely can have discretion
it's just we don't know when it's going
to be applied or not there must be some
other Factor if they're saying may I
mean they seem to list criteria in that
role but they're not saying they shall
do that if you meet that criteria uh
they're still saying that they might do
it well but I mean I guess the concern I
have is the you know the more
the more you try to subscribe in by
saying this factor in this Factory I
mean you're really sort of limiting
their discretion I mean that that's
the rulemaking manual addresses this
issue it tells what you have to do with
criteria you have where you can't list
all the criteria there are things that
you might not consider but would apply
in an individual case you're allowed to
specify examples of criteria two or
three and then have a catch-all at the
end that would apply to anything else
that's unstated you also can have just a
simple General Criterion
which they seem to have in those
individual rules in
59 2204
um
B and C but they're still not saying
shall they're saying may be deferred
may be rescinded
right in 541a 22 does state that no rule
is enforceableness it's been filed and
adopted and so in essence what this
would amount to is oral rule making that
can't be enforced if it's outside of um
like what the director was saying
if they had some kind of catch-all or a
general category of how those decisions
would be made then that would clarify
the issue
the director
however the committee's not required to
object if they feel that this is going
to be applied uniformly and it gives
adequate criteria based on the other
section then you can do what you will
senator
vacuums I I know representative Lynn's
judge is coming out a little bit but
um but I tend to agree with him I think
as you read 2211 when it talks about the
following factors to determine a level
of disciplinary and
sanctions imposed and the duration of
the discipline sanctions so that that
seems to me to say that this is the
criteria that will basically affect your
sentence you know for lack of a better
phrase for the judge
um is that this is the criteria that'll
affect your sentence so they can say
cleanly in a disciplinary action saying
this is the sanction however if you make
these Corrections we can lift that
sanction and that's the sentence right
so that's their sentence so to speak
um so I I think it's clear myself I
think it gives them appropriate
discretion so that a one-time offender
is entreated as a murderer you know so
to speak and so uh I think it's clear
myself I think it gives them the proper
amount of discretion given the factors
that will impact the sentence of for the
Discord action and would the
um
these the actual sanction indicate any
criteria for revocation or suspect or
suspension so that you know this is
suspended for three months while you
take a class or this will be
suspended unless you do unless you do
something else is that generally in the
letter of sanction yes when we issue a
letter A finding letter
um first of all the individual has 10
days to appeal through the Bureau of
appearance of the Department of Safety
but additionally it outlines the
criteria in regards to uh what the
sanction is and what are the if there
are any corrective action requirements
additional training
um that most most of the time is
actually additional training you know
I'm in a specific instance where they
didn't do a procedure properly we would
require additional training and that
could
that could change it from a we would
defer the suspension for a certain
amount of time until that training was
done if they didn't meet that criteria
when the training was done then the
suspension would go like a full
suspension would go into effect
is there a motion moved to approve with
staff edits Becca
any further comments or questions
uh
post
all right thank you very much
so
that leaves us with the
items of consent
the reimbursement for mileage
um so this
is the reimbursement for mileage for
SNAP participants who are doing
employment and training
um and I I have no comments on the rules
thank you madam chair
um we're viewing this it speaks to
reimbursement for public transportation
including but not really limited to taxi
rides bus passes and ride sharing I'm
just concerned about how taxi rides are
public transportation especially because
they can be a more expensive solution
and I'm just curious as to where that
allowance is
uh good morning my name is Nicole
valenzola I'm the rules coordinator over
at the Department of Health and Human
Services I do not have a program area
expert with me today due to the rule
being on consent originally
um
so I don't have that specific answer for
you I
I can definitely uh ask them and get an
answer back to the committee
I know that you know we did look at this
we went through because I actually
pointed out more so that taxi seemed
outdated and so I was like are you
including Uber or something so that
piece was talked about at least from a
noticing it perspective and you know
they didn't raise any
um potential for concern or anything uh
yes please do get back to us on the the
deadline is not until after our next
next meeting so we will postpone this
until the our next meeting Madam chair
yes uh if I could just add a comment so
I live in the Upper Valley where there
is some Advanced Transit available to
our community but of course there are
pretty rural areas as well um where
there are no Uber services in the Upper
Valley or at least not since covid and
um
so I think taxi services are the only
remaining option for many people trying
to get to dhmc for instance for
appointments so I know that that is
probably the only viable Transportation
option if they don't have a vehicle and
are homebound or you know have this
temporary disability given a health care
issue so I just wanted to back up the
department that I know that is a readily
available and probably the only option
for many folks in the Upper Valley
Senator Lang I don't know the same thing
and I think we've capped it with the
number three right behind it says 100
limit per month so regardless of the
transportation services used you're
still capped at 100 bucks a month and I
know in my district Laconia same problem
we don't have public transportation we
do have taxi service we do have Uber but
we don't have public transportation
would be the only way someone could get
around if they didn't have their own car
okay first underfellows yeah just just
to add along that line I mean some
people may be handicapped and there may
be public transportation but that could
be difficult for them so
thank you
um representative
um thank you I have better understanding
about why that's a need and so with this
I don't object to that anymore would you
move to approve yes I'd move to approve
any further discussion thank you
seeing none those in favor
aye opposed
okay thank you very much the dental
services
um so on this particular
item um the only comments I had were
editorial in nature which is why it was
originally on the consent list but
essentially what this rule is doing is
first off there was an update to the
code maintenance committee of the
American Dental Association and how they
code limited Orthodontics and
interceptive Orthodontics before they
were separate now they're combined so
that change was made to replace
interceptive Orthodontics with limited
Orthodontics only the other
change is as a result of
the HB
103 which is amending RSA 285 to extend
dental benefits under Medicaid Managed
Care programs to individuals 21 and
older which became effective on July 1st
2022 this particular rule only
removes a particular
requirement that was needed before in
order to be eligible for dental care
under Medicaid if you were 21 and older
um but that was the only change of me to
these rules what the notice States is
that the implementation of HB 103 is
going to be done by adding a new section
to h e w 506
entitled Medicaid Care Management and
the Departments and the in the process
of doing that
um
so that was the only changes to these
rules thank you representative land
thank you madam chair I was looking to
clarify we had expanded services for the
developmental disability acquired brain
injury and the CFI the independent
living groups for the removable
prostodontics and I just wanted to make
sure that that wasn't being expanded to
everybody 21 plus because that was
intended to be a benefit just for those
communities is that part of the
rulemaking that is coming further from
HB 103
I think the department can better answer
that but based on what I'm reading
um these rules don't really touch on
the dental requirements for 21 and older
it just had a very one sentence with
that strikethrough in it so I would
leave the department to further answer
your question on that
good morning Allison radmay I'm
administrator for the Department of
Health and Human Services the
administrative rules unit again uh this
rule was on the consent calendar so our
Medicaid dental director uh is at
another place at this time
um I can bring any questions back to her
um with respect to Hew Hew 506 uh we
actually just had our public hearing on
that uh this past week and unfortunately
I don't have that file with me here it's
actually on my desk
um so I can't speak to what's currently
in there right now where it's not in
front of me
yes I'm not sure if it would make sense
the deadlines after our next meeting
just to make sure that we're not
extending that or
um I guess I'm looking for guidance I
apologize for pulling these off consent
at the last minute I'm still learning
the ropes and I didn't want to let
something go by unquestioned when I had
a question
representative excuse me Senator line
yeah it's okay whatever
um so
so just to be clear the only real change
in this rule from the previous rule was
due to a coding and billing issue with
the Dental Association and that this
change is to take in account those
billing requirements so that we don't
have a gap correct
and the new rules that representative
Leon is concerned with are in the
process correct and they're not we
expect those to be in front of you
probably May
thank you
and since it went to public hearing this
week the uh the rule itself and any data
from the public hearing is probably
available and um we did not nobody
attended our public hearing
[Laughter]
how sad
representative hacken Phillips no okay
anyone else
right do we have a motion move to
approve second okay
discussion thank you those in favor
aye opposed
all right thank you
um
is that it there were three others that
were the expedited revisions to the
licensure surveys for physicians dental
hygienists and the psychologists
um it was one question in common for all
of those forms okay thank you my
question was that it was removing the
language on all of those um that that
asked if this location was owned by a
hospital system that seems to be a
really important data point for for the
department and for others to have
because the Dynamics of Hospital alone
versus independently owned are different
and I'm just curious if those data are
otherwise available and why that section
has been removed from all three forms
uh Nicole valenzola again Department of
Health and Human Services rules
coordinator
um I can most certainly take that
question back to the program area expert
um so could you just repeat it again
though because I was I was thought I
would maybe able to answer off the top
of my head but I I cannot yes so all
three of them have a question that is
struck on
um let's see it's on on the the first
one for Physicians it's question number
22. could you sorry could you tell me
the um notice number yes 2023-1 okay
which page again on that I'll pull up
the page but I know it was question
number 22. oh question 22. thank you
it's on page eight Nicole thank you
22.
oh the 22 that was struck through not
the new 22. correct okay
and that has been struck from all three
of those forms
probably for the same reason
I maybe I don't know I'll find out for
sure thank you
um
why and then you were saying that you
believe that this is important data so
is it available elsewhere yes if it's
already collected it doesn't I'm not
sure that it needs to be in the
licensure but that is very important
because it changes it it impacts the
Dynamics of our health care System
all right and actually on the Physicians
I did have the question about why we're
getting rid of some of the Specialties
um gynecologic oncology hematologic
oncology have been Consolidated into
oncology I'll pull up which page that is
I just need the notice number again yes
that one is the same 2023-1
and when you get to page
six of the form it's the area of
practice
and gynecologic oncology is struck
oncology in Hematology Oncology is
struck so that it's just hematology so
all of oncology is put into one section
that's been added down below and then
when you get to page seven on the
surgery sub-specialties all of those
sub-specialties have been removed and
there's just the general basket for
surgery subspecialties
and knowing that access to care and
having care here in New Hampshire is
important I'm just curious um why those
data are being removed from these
surveys
with respect to page six the gynecologic
oncology and the hematology and oncology
but including oncology as a one
catch-all beneath just a question as to
why that was done that way yes I'm
curious as to why that's removed because
guys gynecologic oncology there's a lot
of um specific needs with that and and I
think that that that's that's an
important one to call out although I
appreciate that perhaps you're just
consolidating them into tighter buckets
so that you don't have some details
without others
okay
I have a question for oh sorry
uh attorney morals like Mike
um with expiration to forms typically
this would be now
move to a doc you know it was on consent
move to adopt and then it goes in place
and I know they have deadlines with
respect to getting these
surveys out and so I guess I don't know
about when I know you're talking about
like the next gel car or something and
that might be a concern but if the
committee wish this could be postponed
there is no deadline for Committee
Action on expedited revisions to form so
if if the department confers then well
it's up to the committee but to I don't
know if that would cause any heartburn
with the Department this first time
um I know that there are some of these
that need to go active April 1.
and so I don't
I'm sorry
oh right
that's what they're talking about yes
um
if you approve and
um the agency brings back the
information you want and gel cart
dislikes it you could then petition to
have them change the forms again
that's acceptable okay thank you is
there a motion to approve them I'll move
well can we do all three Awards should
we have to do an individual
sorry just again so
because the clarificate for all three of
them was the question
thank you
I started writing the H but
okay so Madam chair I moved to approve
the ex RF 23-1
all right can you just session
representative excuse me director
Phillips uh if committee wishes it could
do all three at once oh we're good 23 1
2 and 4. all right any uh
any further discussion I'm sorry I've
sort of lost track of as to
what we're doing so the emotion is to
approve all three of these expedited
uh Delete
updates with the requests that the
department get back to us and the plan
that if we don't like their answer we
will petition for them to do another
revision of the form thank you
any other questions comments those in
favor hi opposed
did we have a second on that yeah
okay thank you
all right is there anything else that we
need to cover uh cancel the uh continued
meeting
we have nothing else okay
we will uh
we are adjourned and the continued
meeting is canceled
thank you all
and if anybody's interested to hear
finances having a riveting conversation
about hb2